[Music]
uh what's up fam
i'm michael smith he's michael holly
welcome to brother from another
or the best of brother from another and
let me tell you
that's a really challenging endeavor i
mean michael
we spent two hours a day three to five
eastern five days a week on peacock tv
having what we like to think are pretty
interesting conversations and exchanges
to narrow that down to one best of show
oh man you know it's about to be flames
it's gonna be challenging we don't have
short conversations
i think we have conversations that have
some impact we'll let you be the judge
enjoy what you see here
we have had semblances of this
conversation feels like several times on
this show
but it does bear repeating if patrick
mahomes never plays another down he's
one of the greatest to ever do it
hands down right now if he retired
tomorrow
for whatever reason and said you know
what i'm sick and tired of touring with
these people
i'm going to try another sport i'm going
back to baseball he would be a hall of
famer
he is already one of the best to ever
throw a football
if you're a longevity person if you're
about how long somebody has to do and
how many championships i get it
i'm not saying he is better than tom
brady because he beat tom brady
yesterday
okay that's not what i'm saying but i'm
saying we already know what we're
witnessing
just like bobby knight the best quote in
the entire last dance documentary to me
was bobby knight identifying michael
jordan as one of the best the excuse not
one of he said he's the best i've ever
seen play
and this is before michael jordan never
laced it up for the bulls right
before this is in the 80s olympics this
is the olympics
this is the eleven teams one of the best
i've ever seen play
so when i watch patrick mahomes casually
throw it for 462.
just casually like work as a kid say
casually throw for 462.
i'm reminded like we are witnessing
the greatest in progress
if he stays healthy i have no doubt that
he'll go down as the greatest
no argument but right now he's already
one of the greatest and he's 25 years
old
see this is what freaks me out about
patrick mahomes
okay this i i'm legitimately freaked out
by this
because everybody's supposed to have a
weakness right everybody's supposed to
have a weakness
and even the greats if you make him
do fill in the blank then you're going
to get
x result so you mentioned michael jordan
they came up with the jordan rules chuck
daley and his staff came up with the
jordan rules this is what this is what
the jordan rules are we're gonna make
him
he's still gonna be great but we're
gonna make him a little less great
because this is what we can do to him
you mentioned you know
tom brady tom brady oh what do you
hear people say about brady even when he
was in his 20s early 30s in new england
they'd say hey if you pressure him right
up the middle
right up the picture right up right up
the middle for tom brady he doesn't like
that
and he'll still be great but you'll get
a lesser result
i haven't seen that with patrick mahomes
now
i thought bill belichick was going
somewhere when
they they shot him out for a half it
shot him up for a half in the afc
championship game a couple years ago
but then patrick mahomes in the second
half put up 31 points
so i talked to bill o'brien bill o'brien
had him down 24-0
uh in a divisional playoff game
and he wound up with his head spinning
because that deficit was erased
like in a snap i haven't seen patrick
mahomes does he get flustered like dan
marino yelling at his
uh of receivers no not so much i see him
uh you know getting a little animated
every now and then but not to the point
where it distracts
from what he's trying to do uh do you
have to keep him in the pocket
turn him into a runner i wouldn't advise
it because he could run
uh he he doesn't even he doesn't even
run like talking about a michael he ever
knows how he can
he just but no he can't but he just jogs
he's
it's he's like oh let me let me just
grab this this quick five yards and
slide right fast
you know just defense at him he's got to
be the
frustrating player to play we talked a
couple of weeks ago
uh actually two weeks ago against the
raiders and you were frustrated about
how the raiders played them at the end
of the game
the soft coverage that they played i'm
like yeah just gotta go i'm gonna do you
gotta be aggressive do you let him get
behind you because i mean what coverage
do you
do you play against him i look at this
kid now and i marvel at
the fact that we know he's going to get
better i guess if i could compare it to
another basketball player i'd say lebron
james where you knew you were witnessing
something special
and very early on some would say
prematurely
we started to have the lebron jordan
discussion and only recently have
lebron's credentials
caught up with his potential or caught
up with his talent yeah the talent was
already there
now we're looking at the hardware but
i'm but you know
when i watch my homes when i watch my
home that's what i see i see somebody
was like i don't have to see any more
to know that few if anybody have done it
with this much ease is the word michael
let's say he gets multiple rings and
he's got a huge contract and he's got
uh michael holly and michael smith and
many many others in the media
saying all these wonderful things about
him does he lose a little something this
is like hey man i don't have that hunger
i think so
i think he's he's wired differently he's
just wired differently like i mean it's
like but
it's the it's not just the amazing plays
that he makes
and makes routinely at this point
it's also the mistakes that he doesn't
make
i mean he's still only got what two
interceptions this year
and i think he may have one lost fumble
somebody looked that up for me but
he he doesn't so does he get better by
never throwing an interception
you know i mean you know
there was a there was a moment during
the game the telecast yesterday which
will
will break down i have a feeling we'll
be breaking down quite a bit of the
chiefs bucks telecast yesterday
um when tony romo rightfully so
laughed at the threshold because
all of his stats became official because
because he met that qualifying threshold
of 1500 career attempts
so at 1500 career attempts he then
became eligible to have
the best touchdown interception ratio in
nfl history
uh to have the most yards per game in
nfl his travel it was the other stat
i think he's second in yards per attempt
in nfl history highest rated quarterback
in both the regular season and the
postseason
uh in nfl history but uh tony romo
rightfully so
was like oh yeah oh now he's legit now
he's great he wasn't great at 14.99 but
1500 he's got it
and so it just it just makes you it
makes you wonder
just as he goes on and as the game it's
all it already looks like child's play
to him
it already has slowed down for him it
does make you wonder how high he can
take this thing
if he really wants to because even
yesterday i just knew he was going to
throw for 600 yards yesterday
i knew he was going through 600 i'm like
wait a minute let me not change his
channel because
no he didn't have to that's the scary
thing is if he ever has to
so here's here's the next move though
the next move is not
from patrick mahomes because he's
already taken it what do we always hear
from
these smart football people um that
this is a game of adjustments and you're
constantly adjusting so
when you when you and chris sims tried
to make the crazy argument that lawrence
taylor actually did change football
uh i think you guys were trying to say
that the whole blocking schemes changed
because of lt's talent
so the league had to adjust to what this
this person was doing he was amazing so
we got to change
and maybe defensive coordinators and
head coaches now their next move their
next move is
all right uh we get we got a lot of
defensive fronts we got a lot of uh
defensive schemes but we're gonna have
to come up with a home scheme
so we it's gonna have to be some type of
scheme
where we say all right we're gonna have
to live with
one thing one kind of uh performance
from patrick my home but we're taking
away something else i don't even know
what it is
but we didn't know what it was it was my
kids i didn't know what it was
when lawrence taylor when lawrence
taylor first started doing they didn't
know how they were going to deal with it
and they figured it out pretty quickly i
don't know what it is
you mentioned the patriots and there are
teams you know that have slowed him down
relatively speaking you know he doesn't
throw for 460 every game he doesn't
throw four touchdowns every game it may
seem like it
but you know some games he's not
although worldly um
it's just containing him consistently
uh has proved uh practically impossible
what it may be though is just over time
time may catch up to him and i don't
mean catch up to him
but it's and we've talked about this how
long
like travis kelsey is not going travis
kels is an all-time tight end
i think he's on the verge of becoming
the first guy at tight end with 5 000
yard season he's an all-time tight end
travis kelsey is not going to play
forever he's i think six years older
than mahomes if i'm not mistaken
um maybe they're not able to keep the
same caliber of supporting cast around
him
maybe andy reid doesn't coach forever i
know he just did that extension recently
so maybe what stops him from being this
prolific
is through no fault of his own just the
natural attrition that takes place
or the evolution that takes place with
rocks
maybe that's
from his rocking chair at this point
come on in this case i'm not leaving
would make them work
so i i'm i'm looking i'm reaching for
what the league could do to stop him
from owning
[Music]
65 years ago today the late great
rosa parks in the simple
act of defiance of not giving up her
seat
on a montgomery alabama bus was
segregated at the time
she was taken to jail and the montgomery
bus boycott the 382 day i believe
montgomery bus boycott took off as did
the civil rights movement
at the time uh led for the most part by
the late great reverend dr martin luther
king so
a landmark watershed day in our nation's
history 65 years ago today
the beginning of the montgomery bus
boycott and the rest as they say michael
holly is history
yeah you know thank you rosa parks i
think we should always say that
we now never get tired of saying that
can't say it enough thank you rosa parks
and also thank you my citizens of
montgomery alabama because we talk about
rosa and i saw on your feed there's some
other people who don't talk about like
claudette copeland
and i'm sure you'll you'll pick up on on
that in a little bit
there are many people who made this
possible you talked about the length of
the boycott
you can't have something like this with
just
one courageous person in person and she
absolutely was
and i thank her for that but you can't
pull off
a boycott of that magnitude and that
length without
a lot of people being involved a lot of
people being committed to it
and i think that is one of the most
amazing parts
of that that whole story is that it went
on this was a
a tremendous economic shutdown it was a
challenge
to the system and the system lost so
let that be an inspiration to somebody
when you're doing when you're doing
something in the name of justice in the
name of righteousness and you feel like
the system is against you you have to
figure out what's important
to that system and then you can turn
against it and you can turn it over and
that's what happened in montgomery
alabama
yeah i mean to your point the one of the
hallmarks
of the uh the civil rights movement that
that should be
recognized appreciated and it's it's
it's studied and cited quite often
is the level of organization and
sophistication
that took place these weren't
spontaneous
acts of resistance this w whether it's
you know
lunch counter sit-ins or freedom riders
or boycotts
the level of sophistication and the
level of preparation
uh that uh you know these activists
and and these protesters uh submitted
themselves to
in order to to endure what was on the
other side
uh is just incredible um it really is
and there are two
angles of of of the rosa park store in
particular i like to
kind of highlight one is the
you know the uh the
angle of oh well she she was just tired
from a long day's work
and she clarified and corrected that
like no i wasn't tired from a long day's
work i was tired of being oppressed i
was tired of
right systemic racism in the form of
segregation yes
you know sitting on on a bus so when
they when they told her to get up
it was it was hurting two other people
they told him to get up and move because
the bus driver at the time could
could move the sign move the uh the
whites only sign
back uh as needed for more passengers
she got up with the other two and went
and got in the window seat
and then that's the famous picture of
her you know sitting in a window seat so
she wasn't
she wasn't just tired physically she was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
as we still are 65 years later that's
right the other one uh
and you referenced it and i wanted to uh
give her some acknowledgement is
claudette colvin
claudette colvin was 15 years old
and nine months earlier than rosa parks
she was removed and arrested
uh in montgomery for
not adhering to the segregation policy
at the time
and her story isn't as well known
for a lot of reasons one at the time
again she was 15 years old
was nine months earlier i believe she
was actually pregnant
and so the thinking was yeah the
thinking was that
she was a teenager who was pregnant and
therefore carried
less credibility than an adult that
people would respond and resonate more
with rules of parks if she was quote
unquote the right one
and it kind of connected to sports a
little bit there were plenty of players
who were more than
capable of integrating
major league baseball prior to jackie
robinson but remember the thinking was
that he was the quote-unquote
right one and so claudette coven
teenage and pregnant wasn't seen as
somebody that could be a
face of this movement the way that rosa
parks uh in her arrest was
and it really speaks to something that
we deal with today michael holly
uh whether it's you know trial by media
or trial in on the spot in the middle of
the street by police is that
black people have always had this added
burden of having to be perfect
in order to even so much as have our
humanity recognized
because i have to wonder michael what
the ancestors would think about the uh
the debate that captivated uh all of
black twitter
over the last couple of years i'm gonna
try to get through this with a straight
face because
it was fascinating all right so there's
a spot
called true kitchen and cocktails this
is the by the way i'm gonna go and give
myself
props for why the best transition in the
history of television just now going
from rosa parks to twerking
never been done before true kitchen in
cocktails apparently let's hope it's
done
let's hope this is the time where it
that transition actually makes sense
it's never been tried before here's what
anyway
here's why it makes here's why it makes
sense because it it
sparked as most things do with us it
sparked a debate
uh you know a in-house debate
and we'll play the sound with you for it
for you in a second but in case you
didn't see the story on the internet
uh what happened was um it was a brunch
at this you know happening spot in
dallas called
kitchen and cocktails of course yeah
right and things got out of hand
let's just say dj you know dropped some
cash money for the 99 2000 type
playlist whatever come on now and uh
some young ladies decided that
the occasion called for some twerking
all right
and and here's what ensued in case you
missed it there you go
i invested a lot of money into buying
this building into developing this
concept
so black people can have somewhere nice
to go to okay somewhere where we can
feel good about ourselves as a
look stop today and please
somewhere where our people can feel good
about ourselves as a culture okay
no no real talk and so all this twerking
is taking the prime
taking the pink don't bring it here
because we're a restaurant and so beyond
that
75 percent of my customers are ladies
and i'm not mean to show respect for
themselves for how they carry themselves
here so how can i tell the men to
respect themselves
and you guys are talking on last year if
you want to do it you got my restaurant
because i did it for our people and i
did it for our culture so don't do it
don't do it again i don't want to hear
it if you don't like it get out because
i don't need your money
i need to provide something for my
people and don't do it again
thank you
so twitter been on fire about this
that's kevin kelly
uh he's the owner of uh of true kitchen
and cocktails he went ah he he offered a
long a lengthy explanation on instagram
also some security footage and he said
look
my choice of words my language not ideal
but understand that this there was a lot
that led up to this he had asked
politely several times
for his patrons to get off the windows
from the window to the wall whatever
they were doing chill out
you know enough is enough if you fall i
got a lawsuit blah blah blah
and so yeah i mean there's the people of
course people are taking sides on this
like you know did he go too far did they
go too far
is twerking there is it never is there a
writing or right place in time for
twerking i mean
where do you come down on this michael
because this is like you have to declare
your position on this matter this is 20
20. i need you to declare your position
on this
all right well i just want to let me
just let me just roll it mlk i'm looking
down on you
just know rosa and mlk are looking down
on us right now judging us
rose just like go ahead i sat
so they i did not sit so y'all
oh
i know we talked about the steelers i
think i've kind of flipped
from from last week because last week we
kind of went went in on them
after their game was moved from
thanksgiving night to sunday afternoon
at the time that was they had a couple
more moves after that but that was the
first move
thursday to sunday and they were all on
social media saying
this is some bs this is crazy what's
going on we were like hey deal with it
this is cove and all this stuff
but if you if you really think about
what the steelers are going through
uh what they've gone through this season
they did have their bye week taken away
from them
and we all know whether it's football
a physical sport or yapping
on tv nonsense like we do whatever it is
you need some time everybody needs some
time every now and then just to recharge
just to step away from what you've been
doing and to go back at it
they had that taken away from them and
this baltimore situation
has nothing to do with them and it's not
necessarily
oh cove it happens like that's our
that's our default now
well hey you know it's covered times
things happen
no in this cold in these covert times
they didn't do what they were supposed
to do
and because they didn't do what they
were supposed to do i got some stuff for
you on that
yeah pittsburgh went from thursday
to sunday to monday to tuesday
to wednesday at 3 40.
that's unbelievable so i'm telling you
mike
i don't think they're going to go
undefeated but i do think they're going
to win it
because they are a talented team they
are rebels with causes now
this is rebel with the cause and that
like a lot of teams
a lot of teams make it up they make it
up
you guys don't believe in us so you guys
are disrespectful i stopped everybody
thinks you're gonna win
but not only are they 10-0 and
legitimately 10-0
now they they can feel
that the nfl has wronged them because in
many ways the nfl has i think they're
going to win a championship
okay so that dove sails into what i want
to share with you
um i'm saying that we deserve better
as a paying customer if you will
yeah then to see um
practice squad wide receivers play
quarterback or
rg3 and whoever is lining up for
baltimore or play
on a wednesday afternoon but the ravens
do deserve this
and i don't mean to be cruel because
you're talking about a pandemic and a
disease but
they deserve this and they deserve to be
ridiculed and they deserve
punishment on par with anything
anybody's gotten so far based on what
i've come to know so just bear with me
on this
for a second here okay let's go let's go
let's do it cause roger goodell
he said this afternoon you know they're
not looking at a bubble
um the way that the media is looking at
they think the protocols are working
and then i'm looking at some of just the
the up-to-date
notes that's coming through throughout
the day
so like and this one in particular
caught my eye when it came to the ravens
and the steelers game
so they put marquis pouncey on the kova
19 reserve list
today ahead of the game and then they
had
a player and a staff member
test positive today
um but when they found out about begging
partner they found out about the player
testing positive
on the plane baltimore did last night
but it was quote not unexpected and not
a concern for the game and i'm like wait
a second
what are we doing here like how do you
play a game
when you still have positive tests
coming in
like isn't that like in that and they
want a plane like how do we notice that
this isn't spreading as we speak
so i did a little research a little
reporting
and what my source told me is that what
the nfl has
is wait for it a credibility and a pr
problem credibility in the form of
we all know historically that the league
has only given lip service at best to
the subject of health and safety when it
comes to their players
right that's true pr in terms of the
people don't
understand the sophistication of
the system the protocols
that are in place people just don't
understand it because the league isn't
sharing a lot of it but i got a little
bit it fascinates me so hopefully it
doesn't bore you to death but it
fascinates me
you remember that movie that will smith
regina king gene hackman movie animated
state
yes they have enemy of the state i
remember all
will smith movies by the way gps enemy
everything type
gps tracking to track the movements
of players and staff with those
wristbands that they have on
they have data on player movement every
player if you're wearing it
and if you're not you're in the protocol
you're on the reserve list
for the entire season geno stone is the
player
safety for the ravens who tested
positive last night or we pressed it
positive and he found out about on a
plane last night he's the one that they
didn't have any concern about
you know why they can trace the positive
tests
to when exposure took place geno stone
had a maskless conversation
on video per his tracking device
with lamar jackson okay
you know who the super remember the
other day i talked about the super
spreader the other day
in the ravens organization the strength
and conditioning coach
yeah this dude i i kid you not i want to
say something else you not
i kid you not my man was spotting people
on the bench in the weight room
without a mask that's what the strength
conditioning coach was doing so you want
to know why
why they had an outbreak is because
their guy who was symptomatic and not
telling anybody
not wearing a mask was literally in the
weight room spotting people
but it it gets better so marquis ponce
is better than that
well no i'm saying in terms of like just
the sophistication is what i'm saying
because that's pretty crazy that that
alone is crazy but they but they can see
all this and trace it they can
their contact tracing is frankly like
nobody else has not just the rapid
testing but the contact tracing so check
this out
um marquee's pouncey uh
goes on the covet list today i'm like
wait a second like
does that mean that somebody else may
have it where do you get it from got it
from a family member
and it's not been any in contact with
any teammates so isolated on the list
crisis averted and so i think for people
on the outside looking at this saying
wait a minute like shouldn't they shut
this down or
how can they determine whether or not to
play or not they know more than they let
us know
about how to isolate this thing
how to identify that's really the source
of it
and that's why they feel comfortable
playing games when people are still
testing positive because they know
tested positive
not only do they know who tested
positive they know where they got it
from
and with whom they've been in contact
literally down to the movement
[Music]
[Music]
russell westbrook going from houston to
d.c
john wall going from d.c to houston not
just john wall going there but a first
round pick a protected first round pick
i get it
that's big but a first round pick go in
there
and the only thing mike i don't
understand here well i don't understand
a couple of things here
but just uh i can help you the little
side piece a little side piece here is
that
washington dealt as if it didn't have
leverage
like don't you know james harden james
harden didn't want russell westbrook
there anymore
they were going to move one of those
guys they were
pretty much locked up contractually they
don't have any draft picks
so you don't have to do what you don't
want to do unless
unless the wizards
thought that something else was
happening that we that we're not aware
of i'm not sure what it is they didn't
have to give up a first-round pick
to get russell westbrook as my point i'm
interested
to say that because both of us are
westbrook fans
yes just happens to recognize his flaws
a little bit better than the other one
yeah but
i thought that would be a no-brainer
from your perspective at least because
the best player in the trade
is russell westbrook not just the best
russell westbrook but the healthiest
player
so i get the first round sweetener
if you're washington and you want to
move on
from your former number one overall pick
and your former face of the franchise
who while younger uh is not as good a
better shooter which isn't saying much
but not as good um and you move on from
him
and bringing a guy who your head coach
is quite familiar with
i mean i think if you're the wizards you
upgraded so that first round pick
is a price worth paying if you're
houston
and this is where i start that's one
where i'm going to start but
just to dovetail off of that yeah i got
to give a shout out to rafael rolling
stone
i'm a new general manager daryl moore's
replacement
well i i thought they were stuck like
chuck you know that
you know especially when the trade
rumors and the reports of uh
you know unrest within that organization
and your two superstars both wanted out
for different reasons
all that stuff started happening i'm
like look you're not gonna get better
around these two
maybe you can get different so to speak
but you're not gonna get better
so might as well blow it up you know
everybody's playing for second
in the nba right now to the lakers
anyway this isn't a championship roster
don't get mired in mediocrity any more
than you already are you know
trade them both i said because there's
not much you could do you kind of you
know
the the cupboard's bare when it comes to
assets as you mentioned earlier but
raphael stone is fooled around and
he went and stole christian wood from
the pistons okay
see that's a good that's what we love we
both love that
first stage robert covington to portland
for ariza
the 16th pick and a 2021 protected pick
if i'm not mistaken
they flip ariza and the 16th pick
to detroit for christian wood
love that pickup for them right so they
get him
getting rid of westbrook for wall
there's some upside there okay to get
wall back
because whoa maybe he gels better
than russell westbrook did who knows but
because wall washing
joe's better with harden with hard and
i'm sorry yes
that then okay then russell westbrook
did and look john
let me john wallace let me remind me to
come back to that
okay no problem i'll be quick but john
wall that's some upside there if he
if he's actually as good as he's
reportedly looked in workouts coming off
the achilles
then it's not like they they got a scrub
back for russell westbrook they got a
pretty damn good player
a fellow five-time all-star great note
by the way
two times in nba history have players
who each have five all-star appearances
minimum five all-star appearances been
traded for each other
chris paul russell westbrook russell
westbrook john wall so
this is somewhat unprecedented what
we're seeing here we'll get to the
ripple effects in a second
but point being is if you're using you
get back john wall
so you remain competitive and i'll get
to this in a second too you remain
attractive
to uh your current partner as in james
harden
and you get this protected first round
pick back so now you've
gotten back two picks this off season if
i'm tracking this right
one from um from portland
and one from uh now the wizards
so you're kind of restocking the
cupboard if you will and listen i don't
know what demarcus cousins has
left but that's a high up that's a low
low risk
high reward move to bring in demarcus
cousins let's just leave
i like that let's
hey look maybe it makes john wall happy
i don't know point being is
they're tinkering and i like what rafael
stone has done he's done a lot with a
little it looked like
how are they going to get out of this
mess and he's reshaped the team i just
got off the radio with rich eisen a
second ago
and he was like this is just shuffling
furniture on the deck is all this is i'm
like yeah but sometimes your apartment
or your house can look totally different
just by moving furniture around i don't
know about you but yeah my mom all the
time she loved to move furniture
and i come in i'd be like damn did we
move this is like a different house so
far
that's pretty good so it could it but
you know what but you know what happens
in that case
i love that analogy but let's just stick
with that analogy just for a second
when you move things around in your
house and initially you say
man i never really appreciated this
window or this
table in this alignment and then after a
while you get used to it and say it's
just the same old place
so i don't believe i don't believe that
we're in that situation because like you
actually said off the top
i think russell westbrook is such a
dynamic underappreciated player
my only question here for washington yes
he is the best player
in the trade and i say wait until uh
when the east meets west
westbrook because he's never been in the
eastern conference and he has done some
damage out west which has
historically been the stronger
conference and he has done
his best work there when he gets to the
east
i think his numbers will stay the same
if not rise
my question is they've got a fun looking
lineup i like the lineup is pretty fun
i do that's my problem interesting
play-in team type i think the best
best situation for russell westbrook and
go back a little bit here
just so you can see the
the comparison when allen iverson
played for philly they're always like
that second scorer
you know larry hughes for a while jerry
stackhouse worldwide all these second
scores they didn't quite fit
with alan iverson and eventually larry
brown said all right
best way to feature allen iverson let
him do his thing
it just let me just liquidate the roster
of scorers
you know yeah so he's playing with like
george lynch
and eric snow and uh time maintenance
that would be tyrone hill that was his
nickname time name this great nickname
but all these guys in dikembe so
a lot of guys who didn't demand the ball
and that's when alan iverson really
started to flourish in philadelphia went
to the nba finals
i really believe that russell westbrook
is at his best
when he can just dominate the ball some
people call it a ball hog i'm not so
judgmental
i say let russ cook and that's how russ
cooks
hey that's and that's marked hey be
careful that's trademark
a guy in seattle i think he trademarked
that shout out russell wilson
shout out i like you like you on ig too
do some good stuff
um but can russell westbrook really
reach his his his mark his his uh his
best place with bradley beal because
bradley beal
is a bad boy bad boy he got himself last
year
and would he like it well he liked it
oh
you and i have already crowned the
lakers uh we've declared that everybody
is playing for second
so the seasons of formality and speaking
of formalities
they before yesterday or was it
yesterday they all run together for me
now lebron did a two-year extension
85 million dollars kepler 23.
wow and then anthony davis there's a lot
of speculation about whether anthony
davis is going to do some kind of
shorter deal or
how he was going to try to manipulate
his situation five year one
190 million dollar max um
so i have commentary on both
but i will pass it to you because i want
i want you to talk about the lakers
extending not only
these two contracts but extending their
windows yeah i mean i
i think you know in baseball
you know baseball managers always say
hey it's easier for me to build a
bullpen
if i know i've got a closer at the back
end who can shut it down
so once i know i got that that guy at
the back
i can go forward and build the rest of
my best of my
rest of my bullpen and just like a
pitching staff you know your pitching
staff is good you got an ace
and if you got a number two oh you're
good i mean
really you're good you think about the
postseason you don't need five
all you need is like three or four
sometimes right with the lakers with
lebron james there was no question
lebron james was going to stay
uh but the two-year extension just makes
it official and i think the same thing
with anthony davis
but you know going forward mike that you
have
a star who not only
has the age has the has a profile that
you're looking for
but this is where i think this is how
dynasties
extend when you can have
uh the junior member for the sword for
the for the
purpose of this conversation you can
have the junior member
of the of the duo anthony davis
win a championship with the lead dog
in lebron practice with him travel with
him
have conversations with him so when it
is eventually
lebron's time to leave anthony davis is
not asked sitting around asking
how's this work like this is critical
what's happening now with the lakers
this is not just a championship window
for for 20 20 21
having anthony davis there for the long
term
means that if when lebron decides that
he's
he doesn't want to play anymore anthony
davis is now positioned as that guy
who could bring somebody along just like
lebron did it for him
this is this is really great news for
the lakers
i just want to talk about a.d
particularly in particular i'll start
with that then because
you know we know in new orleans that he
couldn't break through which is why he
wanted to go to la
he goes to la he makes first team
all-nba
wins a title alongside lebron
i believe he's 27 years old
michael forget about like matching up
money forget about draft pick
packages players i'm not talking about
literally
but you look across the nba tell me a
player
that you would give up anthony davis in
order to acquire
like i'm not saying he's the best player
in the nba
yeah right but i'm saying there's nobody
i'd rather have
right given what he does at both ends of
the floor he's he is a
singular transcendent talent
has been for some time now he's got the
stage to showcase that talent
and there's not a player that i find to
be more
valuable whether he wins an mvp or not i
want to talk about the king real quick
though
because a number that you may have seen
yesterday when he got that
extension 85 million over two years
it will bring his career total to 435
million dollars
the most money all time and keep in mind
that for the first i think dozen years
of his career he wasn't the highest paid
player on his team
but check this out though not to not to
get into another jordan
lebron debate but i am going to repeat
sort of what i said a while ago which is
that
it's useless debating them because
they're so different
i want to marvel momentarily michael at
the mogul
at the master manipulator you talked
about this
what a great team builder lebron james
is not just team building
the businessman the business
man that he has been waiting for it i
was waiting for it there it is career
when you talk about how it was a juicy
rebound right
how he's managed his contracts
to maximize leverage and and flexibility
how he's moved and taking his individual
dynasty from franchise to franchise
how to go back to our boy alonso he's
playing chess
not checkers he's changed the game when
it comes to player agency
that he now for all intents and purposes
has a player agency
okay where
people move differently because of him
and that's just
within basketball that's not even
talking about
uninterrupted or the i promised school
i mentioned clutch sports the the media
entertainment mogul most people wait
till they're done to do this
he's done them both he's been dominant
on the court and off the court
in a way that nobody else has
in a unique unparalleled way i'll say to
you like this michael
you could debate whether or not he is
the best to ever play the game but it is
indisputable that anybody
in not just nba but maybe even sports
history
has ever played the game capital t
capital g nobody's ever played that game
quite like this dude that's right that's
right and
and the game was the game was set up in
a way
where he was not supposed to be able to
meet
the expectations that were laid out for
him we've seen this story many times
it just he was he was set up he was
he was set up to succeed there was a
path to that
that path was a little more narrow then
he was also set up to fail
which is the more likely path believe it
or not because when you are
when you are uh a national name
when you're 14 or 15 years old and a
whole state
is following you around when you're 15
16
and you're uh on magazine covers and
you've got an
endorsement deal a 90 million dollar
endorsement deal before you even go to
the nba
oh you have all of this attention when
your high school says
no your games are not in this high
school gym anymore
no no no you're too big for that you're
high school we're going to the
university of akron
because if we're going to have personal
seat licenses
in high school for you to accommodate
your talent
yes in high school okay
so all of these things and you're the
number one pick
and you're playing for the local team
at some point somebody's a hater will
look at that and say well the guy can't
be that good come on now come on
come on 90 million dollars come on god
never played in the league all this
and he exceeded think about those
expectations that were set for him
and he exceeded that
[Music]
so here it is and i got to tell you i
told you uh in the beginning of the show
i've been emotional
lately i think this is part of the
reason uh for the emotions i get
emotional
when i write these books because i
realize
that's really not about me it's about uh
like all the people who have helped me
get to this position where i can just
where i can do these things and so every
every book represents the story and the
story of this book as i told you before
uh it's dedicated to my grandparents
uh who both were so instrumental
in making me the man i am today as i've
said uh
many times i'm still trying to get to to
where they were
because i'd always look at their lives
and say wow you do this when you were 20
you did this when you were 30.
yeah here i am older than 20 older than
30 and saying man i'm i'm not where i am
now
as an adult where they were coming up
so very inspiring my grandparents uh
just like they
they've inspired me to achieve and then
the other thing is
this book represents overcoming fear
believe it or not it's my first
basketball book i say believe it or not
because i covered basketball for many
years
and it's the sport the sport i played
in quotes wasn't very good but it was
the one sport
that i was really obsessed with as a kid
yeah but i was afraid to write a
basketball book
there's so many good basketball books
out there and i'd always come up with
excuses
of why i wasn't going to write a book
and this one took took the first note on
this one
eight years ago why
fear fear i come up with all kinds of
excuses so
now that i've overcome this fear
i feel like i'm just starving
[Music]
you